new fear unlocked climbing the Rope at
the gym
I got oh that is really scary I would
probably relax my arms a bit and just
dead hang at that point
Final Destination is real oh my God
honestly this is one of my biggest fears
not just with a piece of wood like this
that obviously can happen but what about
when it's cold and Ice freezes over on
those trucks and they don't clean it off
and then as a result giant icicles are
flying at you 70 miles an hour I always
have a fear of that I'm always looking
out I got a call from one of the staff
ladies had a heart attack in the middle
of a cooking class so I ran down I was
there in three minutes the lady's lying
on the ground and you started chest
compression chest compression chest
compressions after calling for help
there's a guy holding a pulse he said
the pulse is gone Chaska brushes
no not cayenne pepper got a half a
teaspoon
quickly put it in the mouth she was half
conscious
wait hold on a second the story is
already full you cannot be without a
pulse and be half conscious and have
someone be able to drink water if you're
a pulseless that means your heart is not
beating that means you are not conscious
all the color came back into her cheeks
and she sat up and said what happened
then she had a vasovagal response to
something
[Music]
you do need Warfarin depending on your
medical condition this is the problem
when people speak out of turn and not
know what the heck they're talking about
patients who have atrial fibrillation
whose hearts beat irregularly the blood
that's in the heart stagnates and can
form a clot and then that clot ends up
shooting into the brain creating a
stroke in young people this happens this
is devastating Strokes have lasting
effects if not lethal effects and this
lady instead of telling you to take a
medication that will prevent the clot
from forming through proven scientific
research it does come with risks
legitimate risks but anything that
actually works comes with risks says you
can replace it with cayenne pepper that
has almost no risk outside if you're
maybe allergic to it or something and
she thinks that's going to work better
bro come on stop with this nonsense no
need
for aspirin no need for your video
delete it off social media it has been
shown today that aspirin causes brain
bleeds yes aspirin causes brain bleeds
because it actually thins your blood
this is very very safe with no side
effects because it doesn't work
patience I don't need a chiropractor I
could do it myself
oh wow okay this is
I why would you do this is this like
some kind of myofascial treatment I'm so
confused
are you showing how strong he is I would
just never do this you risk damaging so
many vital tissues for no reason and
something bad happened what happened um
I'm nervous right now right now what
happened oh it literally goes oh my God
that's a that's a very serious edematous
response probably allergic response
potentially infectious I would need IV
steroids in a situation like this not
just oral unfortunately I see this
happening more and more with unregulated
people doing injections because people
think they would save money they'd go to
this individual please please please
only go to certified legitimate doctors
doing this
oh no not another one of these videos
come on
time see boxers do this uh with a
medicine ball a padded medicine ball to
strengthen the abdominals to allow you
to breathe uh easily with a tight
abdominal if need be here they're just
doing it once you're not getting
anything from that you're not toughening
people up so that was purely for sure
okay is this a tampon
we use something in medicine called
rhino rocket which almost acts like a
tampon it's a tamponade really bad
nosebleeds it probably just dried up in
there that's why it's stuck it's not
actually stuck from all the pressure if
you use sauna one day a week your risk
of dying of all things goes down like 30
to 40 percent
I have patients that die of legitimate
things imagine if I told them like yo
there's a gym and down the block that if
you use their sauna you just cut your
chance of dying by a third no
30 30 40 it's the same as when we start
looking at these ridiculous studies that
say if you eat 12 almonds a day you
extend your life by 14 years no it does
not work by this level of extrapolation
you have to be honest of what you do
with Statistics if you use song three
times a week you never die and you're
superhuman why don't you just stay in
the sauna for 10 hours and see what
happens guess what you die and your
whole thing Falls flat on his face Jeff
here don't compare my hand to someone
else's looks like a big hand yes could
be my wife since she's handy
wow he has a very big hand or his wife
has a very little hand oh wow he has
really big hands is this like lymphedema
or he naturally has big hands Jeff dabe
he's from Minnesota and he was born with
these giant hands and arms like Popeye
and University of Minnesota has tested
extensively and there's no idea what's
going on wow so no no medical reason
just genetically unique do you have a
really really bad sore throat where it
hurts to swallow the number one cause of
a really sore throat is a viral
infection a lot of people think they
need antibiotics for a sore throat
that's not always the case we only give
antibiotics for strep throat and why we
give it specifically for strepto is to
prevent the complications of strep
throat like rheumatic fever this is one
of the things in Chinese medicine that
we do that's really simple okay I'm
always down for a tip that has nothing
to do with antibiotics so let's see
where she's going with this so what
you're going to do is actually prick to
bleed um lung 11. come on man honey tea
chicken noodle soup salt water gargles
why are you pricking anything just give
me any logic behind this
take it and you just poke and you create
an opening for an infection and the
effects of it would be very immediate no
they wouldn't be very immediate because
if you could you would study this and
you would prove that this works
immediately because it's such an easy
thing to study and you don't because it
doesn't work RNA all by itself yep RNA
single stranded and then we need to
mirror it
they're dancing there is the DNA bond
created in harmony 13 yards oh my gosh
oh
oh a lot of vital structures in there
prostate perineum blood vessels
testicles
ice skating training as well oh yeah
this is incredible
oh my God I would throw up so badly
oh my God the disequilibrium is
affecting me I mean I could see why you
would need to train because they do
similar stuff like that on skates all
day long
the worst luck okay we have a baseball
batter at a batting cage
what happened
what
oh took one right to the jaw right to
the mandible fracture ow some Push-Up
Bars oh okay dip into oh that's hard to
do oh yeah that hurt I mean that wasn't
that great of a distance but dang that
hurt if you're older age usually younger
people won't be an issue you could get a
severe compression fracture of your
spine which is so painful also you
you're at risk for a disc bulge or disc
herniation which are those soft padded
sacks that give cushioning in between
the vertebrae in between the bones
workouts to do as an ER nurse CPR that's
good on the bosu ball you know it'll
help uh strengthen the triceps the back
this form is perfect I would say
when I get a piercing random pain under
my left boob and I try to breathe fully
[Music]
cordial catch syndrome it happens in
young people where it feels like you
can't really take a full breath because
there's like a weird pain that happens
under your rib also can happen with a
spasm of the intercostal muscles the
muscles that exist in between ribs but
anytime you have pain on the left side
of your chest and that's not going away
it comes with other symptoms that's an
emerging call that you have to make to a
medical professional okay we have an
individual who's doing a glute exercise
of some kind
yeah um no there's better ways to do
this just do like a split Squad of
Bulgarian split squat that hyper
lordosis of the lumbar spine is going to
cause an ache down the line let me take
a picture
so in order to get a proper x-ray you
need the child to sit still and unless
the child's asleep or sedated you're
gonna have to put them in one of these
tubes to get a really clear x-ray
[Music]
very true also there's a lot of
ingredients within food that have long
names that aren't actually bad for you
at all in fact you can talk about some
common foods and make it sound like it's
something terrible I remember there was
this old Penn teller skit can I get you
guys to sign a petition Banning
dihydrogen monoxide causes excessive
sweating excessive urination that's dye
hydrogen monoxide
eating an orange the shower will help
decrease anxiety and depression while
boosting your overall mood due to the
Citrus aroma
what is the trend eating an orange in
the shower why
whether you eat the orange in the shower
out of the shower the effects will not
change if you like citrus Aroma use some
Citrus soap get a citrus air freshener
my day as an influencer in the 1600s
okay
drinking water 10 to the fire
hunt for evidence of witches
die of dysentery yeah a lot of people
used to die if things just like diarrhea
can you imagine because we didn't have
IVs IV saline solution like normal
saline solution has really saved lives
by the millions not exaggerating ah
ah my vertigo is kicking in hard here is
this bungee jumping
oh my God oh my God you know bungee
jumping just doesn't look healthy to me
because once you get to the bot
obviously like if the Rope is too long
it's definitely not healthy but if the
Rope is even the right length that jolt
that you get to your neck like I feel
like that can cause a lot of problems
coconut oil I mean Lots okay lots of
coconut oil is high in saturated fat
which we know will raise your
cholesterol which we know increases your
risk of having heart disease and stroke
is a remedy for Alzheimer's oh it's a
remedy for Alzheimer's we in the medical
community have zero remedy for
Alzheimer's but this gentleman says
coconut oil so you just have to take the
extract of coconut oil which is MCT oil
no dosing no people who this is good for
not good for I'm all for saying the
Pharma industry is bad and has so many
problems but at least they do safety
profile testing they give you
indications who this is good for who
it's not good for when someone just
comes on and just says this thing is
good for this thing no proof behind it
no dosing behind it be hyper skeptical
in fact this person's lying MCT has
ketones in it with all the Damage Done
to to the brain through all the sugar
and stress the brain cells just aren't
getting fuel and they die there's little
bits of like real science in this and
then it just gets absolutely corrupted
into nonsense word salad I'm gonna snap
to the nose I'm gonna catch them on
gallbladder because I don't want to
break it on gallbladder guy gallbladder
right here not here Cranium we're gonna
reach in into the large and small
intestine 18.
you mean into the mandible into the
maxillary sinus
this is full acting BS he did not make
that person pass out and all of the
other people are in on it when they jump
in to try and rescue this person what
are we watching
oh pitting edema
this can go all the way from one plus to
four plus as you can see here we use a
grading scale and there's different
reasons why people have edema a lot of
times I'll see this in my patients who
have congestive heart failure so they
have a buildup of fluid as a result of
the increased pressure that the heart
has to pump against or that the heart is
failing and not being able to pump as
effectively now Merriman I'm looking at
after the the day families are pushing
feds to
pushing the feds to so it's interesting
in situations like this where a person
can't find the words to speak has been
discussed as potential Strokes so I
don't know what happened here it's hard
to say but there's definitely slurring
of speech unable to find words sorry
Airman I'm I'm not feeling very well
right now and I'm about to okay well
come back to me right now we'll make
sure that Jessica you are doing okay her
pupils look blown she looks like she's
about to lose Consciousness for all we
know this could be a response to her
being hypoglycemic and having low blood
sugar so like unclear what happened I
actually have a whole video right here
of medical emergencies that happen to be
caught by TV cameras check this out
you'll learn a lot and as always stay
happy and health
[Music]
thank you